are we experiencing deja vu what is that
we swear we've seen some of these disney
scenes before
that's right today we're looking at
disney movies and how some material from
old movies
have made it into the new movies are
these references fun little easter eggs
or is it just a coincidence we'll let
you be the judge
in the end credits of lilo and stitch we
see a montage of photos that depict
stitch
with his new family in one picture we
see stitch helping a baby sea turtle out
to sea by holding a leaf over it
adorable now let's look at moana at the
beginning of her film
she assists a baby sea turtle in the
same style leaf protection and
all
we could help but wonder why the
creators decided to do this
was it a coincidence or a clever sneaky
reference
either way both stitch and moana look
cute saving the baby sea turtle
in frozen we're heartbroken when anna
transforms into a nice statue
as she sacrifices herself to save her
sister we see it happen again
in the movie sequel frozen 2 but this
time with elsa
when she freezes it's because she
ventured too deeply into attaholin to
find out the secrets of the past
whereas anna froze because she had to
stop hans from hurting her sister
she too is making a sacrifice when she
turns to ice
but this time it's for the fate of magic
in their world
not only are their sacrifices similar
but disney utilizes a lot of the same
imagery and shot composition
[Music]
look closely for this next one in big
hero 6
there's a picture of ant cass's cat
mochi dressed up as stitch
from lilo and stitch if you look even
closer you'll notice that
mochi is dressed up as stitch when
stitch is in his alien uniform
the one he's in at the beginning of the
movie he is bulletproof
fireproof and can think faster than
supercomputer
it's an adorable in-movie cosplay and
it's perfect that mochi is in costume
rather than hiro
or tadashi stitch is lilo's pet and
mochi is hiro's pet
that's perfect oh that darn cat
we know ant cass from big hero 6 but it
looks like she's also on the cover of an
ad in wreck-it ralph
too she's posed exactly the same as she
is in this scene
where she's talking to hero it's almost
like they took a screenshot from big
hero 6 and
inserted it into wreck-it ralph 2. we
can't help but wonder why they chose ant
cass to be the cover of the ad
but it does make for a great cameo she's
definitely rocking it
only eagle-eyed fans will have spotted
this next one
check out the corkboard in this scene of
big hero 6. see a familiar face
that's right it's hans from frozen he's
a wanted man in this universe
it looks like he's a bad guy in frozen
and in big hero 6.
word must have spread from aarondale to
san fransokyo
about his terrible misdeeds and what he
did to anna and elsa
hans isn't just a wanted man in big hero
6. he's also a fancy statue at fred's
mansion
it's so satisfying to watch baymax blow
up the frozen villain's likeness
after all he is one of the worst disney
antagonists out there
who wouldn't want to see his statue
blown up
in frozen anna stuffs her face with
chocolate during the first time in
forever sequence
it's a relatable moment but look closer
at that pile of chocolate
we've seen it before in wreck-it ralph
it makes sense that anna's eating sugar
rush chocolate
after all wreck-it ralph came out the
year before frozen so it makes sense for
the movie to have a cameo
these easter eggs are hard to spot so
keep your eyes out
multiple disney princess symbols can be
seen in rapunzel's tower entangled we've
got snow white's apple
cinderella's slippers aurora's spindle
ariel's shell
and belle's rose and dresser the
creators paid homage to almost all of
rapunzel's predecessors
do these movies all take place in the
same universe or do they just
all have the same interior decorator or
maybe it's a treat to avid disney fans
you decide
the character finnick makes for a cute
elephant in zootopia when he and nick
visit an elephant ran ice cream shop
to pull off their con finnick needed to
dress up in order to get sympathy from
the elephants
making them bend their elephants only
policy
but he isn't just dressed as an adorable
baby elephant
he's cosplaying dumbo look at how big
those ears are
the kakamora are a fearsome antagonist
in moana
but there's one friendly face hiding in
the crowd can you see it it's baymax
from big hero 6.
it doesn't look like he's here to be a
healthcare provider though
coconuts
it's sweet to see elsa and anna as kids
playing with snow toys before bed but
those aren't just regular toys they're
characters from past movies we spotted
dumbo
baymax and bolt it's so cute that elsa
and anna are playing with the snow toys
that elsa magicked up but it's even
cuter that the creators chose to feature
past characters
the final battle between claude frollo
and quasimodo
is intense for sure but you might not
have noticed a disney favorite hiding in
plain sight
look at the gargoyle in this scene it's
pumbaa from the lion king
the lion king pre-dates the hunchback of
notre dame by two years
so it's fitting that the lovable wartog
makes an appearance in the film
mrs potts from beauty and the beast has
an iconic character design
let's watch the trash and the camp
sequence of tarzan
turk is playing a tea set that looks an
awful lot like mrs potts
and her accompanying tea set how did
jane porter and her father come to
acquire that tea set anyway
they must have bought it at the disney
store that's amazing
an important object in up is the grape
soda pin
ellie first gives to carl as a symbol of
their friendship
it's later given to russell as a junior
wilderness explorer badge
but it looks like it's been abandoned
and lost just like woody
in toy story 4.
at the beginning of tangled we watch a
beautiful magical flower blossom
but it won't be the last time we see it
used in one of disney's films
this flower plays an important role in
tangle as it gives rapunzel's hair
its powers and it plays a small role in
moana when life returns to matunui
one of the first flowers to bloom is the
tangled flower
the flower ends moana whereas it begins
tangled
the magic carpet from aladdin is famous
for being able to travel around the
world
it looks like it traveled to motenui
from moana maybe aladdin is hiding
somewhere on the island with jasmine
after all there is that sequence in
aladdin where he jasmine and the flying
carpet visit
every corner of the world who's to say
they didn't stop at motenui
the finger fun is a classic move
hercules shoots one at meg when he's
about to save her from a fearsome
monster
excuse me similarly maui shoots one at
moana when he's introducing himself
both of these characters have a lot in
common they're super strong
they're demigods and they're heroes
we met them in finding nemo but it looks
like moana met crush and squirt when she
was a baby
watch this scene when moana looks at two
sea turtles passing by
those aren't just any turtles their
crush and squirt from finding nemo
maybe this is crush and squirt's origin
story maybe they're actually from
motunui before traveling to australia
sweet totally
many fan theories that connect the
little mermaid and frozen
and the two are indeed related agner
reads a book by some danish author
in a memory in frozen two that danish
author is hans christian andersen
you'll recognize him as the author of
the short story the little mermaid
and the snow queen stories that became
disney's the little mermaid and frozen
in fact you can see ariel on the cover
of the book agnar is reading
the tapestry of merida's family plays an
important role in brave
and it makes an appearance in cars too
it shows up in a pub during the london
grand prix
and the setting for brave is scotland
part of the united kingdom so it makes
sense that it would show up there
both movies are also part of the pixar
family so it makes even more sense that
the creators would reference brave
in cars 2. it looks like disney loves to
drop references from the old to the new
especially in its more recent films like
moana and frozen 2.
we love to watch disney movies for their
plots and characters and
songs and we love to re-watch disney
movies to find
all the fun little easter eggs they've
hidden for us which one was your
favorite let us know
down in the comments thanks for watching